Viva lights that's the biggest possibly
the biggest cinco de mayo party In The
City Las Vegas lights soccer club back
on the field this weekend with a regular
season home opener and look who it is
once again it's the EO Brett Lashbrook
from the Las Vegas lights football club
I should say Brad good to see you once
again this morning great to be here it's
good to see you uh let's talk soccer uh
it's the regular season home opener a
lot of big things are planned you've
brought some of it with you there what
are you is that a uh what is Friday it's
Cinco de Mayo of course right so what
are we going to do we're gonna do the
biggest cinco de mayo party in the whole
city One of a Kind never before it will
be our home opener uh simultaneously
going on with Luchador wrestling
throughout the game Big Valley wrestling
giving away its championship title belt
at halftime we got a special deal you
can get your own lights Luchador masks
good for all ages his hair's too pretty
won't put it on we got we got Cinco de
Mayo scarves that we're putting on
unbelievable deals it'll be a fun fun
night on Friday night and then we come
back again for Family Day on Sunday
afternoon two home games this weekend
love to see that and you know a lot I've
been to lights games before but for
folks that haven't been out to Cashman
to see a game there what's the
atmosphere like trying to describe what
it is to be a lights fan it's the
world's most popular sport in the
world's entertainment Capital right but
it is hyper local look at it on the
screen right there it is something that
you just won't see in the other sports
here uh in in Las Vegas and I mean that
in a positive way we all have our Niche
this is the Little slice of Mexico City
Buenos Aires Barcelona
they'll be singing they'll be dancing
they'll be confetti there may be some
llama masconots and Elvis mascot right
there on a Harley-Davidson at the
beginning of the game it will be the
world's most popular sport with a unique
Vegas Twist on it and we were talking
before it's now what five years for a
loss for it's like our sixth season this
is our sixth home opener so it's it's
really exciting again to see how not
just how we've grown but also the city
and its Sports Enterprise has grown
around us well on that note let's talk
about that what's next for for lights FC
you know you've been around for a while
now established over at Cashman what's
what's next for the franchise just
continue to grow right I would say as
the as the community continues to grow
as we become not just the entertainment
Capital world but the sports
entertainment Capital World there is
absolutely a niche for the world's most
popular sport here and we're proud to
play that role uh and support all levels
of the game here how's the team look
this year we're looking good we're
looking good only one loss after six
games coming home strong uh so very
excited last week we played a major
league soccer team held him scoreless
for 105 minutes unfortunately in the end
didn't get to get the win but coming
home Friday night I think it'll be a big
crowd and a big uh a big result it's the
regular season home opener on Cinco de
Mayo I mean that's about the best
party in the city right all ages are
welcome we'll have food and beverage
specials you want Jarritos Mexican Cola
you want Estrella Mexican beer you want
especially tacos you want a skeet Acorn
we got it it's going to be fantastic and
if you can't make it Friday night you
come out Sunday afternoon next time you
come please be more energetic I will I
will put me on the five o'clock hour
Brett Lashbrook for the Las Vegas lights
thanks for coming once again appreciate
the time thank you Viva